und fasse ich mal wieder wird science
fiction zur realität in der dna einer
bakterie also im erbgut wurde jetzt
schadsoftware versteckt und auf diesem
weg tatsächlich ein computer gekapert
das ist wirklich unvorstellbar und macht
auch ein bisschen ans ab sofort können
auch bakterien computer infizieren
welche gefahren von bio hecking ausgehen
jetzt in kriegszeiten herzlich
willkommen
den eigenen computer mit einer
erkältung oder schlimmer anzustecken
fast unvorstellbar oder doch
tatsächlich ist jetzt so etwas gelungen
erstmals wurde ein computer auf
biologischem umweg mit einer
schadsoftware infiziert aber eigentlich
noch schlimmer denn für die bakterie
oder den menschen war der coach wohl
ungefährlich erst im computer wurde er
in dem bakterium aktiv und verpasste ihm
eine verheerende krankheit
der ganze vorgang ist ziemlich komplex
aber gleichzeitig auch unheimlich
faszinierend
der erste schritt bestand darin eine
schad software zu programmieren einen
sogenannten exploit das werkzeug
überhaupt für alle hackers dieser welt
wurde programmiert dieser binärcode
wurde dann in einem zweiten schritt in
eine dna sequenz umgewandelt dna besteht
ja aus vier charakteristischen baustein
den nuklearen adenin thymin guanin und
cytosin kurz atg und c befindet teil
nicht so wichtig um das verfahren zu
verstehen wichtig ist nur das ist
einfach eine buchstabenfolge ist die
hier in die dna eingebaut werden muss
diese bestimmte sequenz die also von den
binärcode abgeleitet war lief ein
forschungsteam herstellen und zwar bei
einem kommerziellen dienstleister für
mich meinen neun stick soll aufsucht
wird habe ich es verraten es waren also
keine kriminellen ja und dann lagen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
diesen künstlichen dna strang wieder
aus in der rolle des opfers heißt wir
nutzen jetzt einen computer auf dem ein
programm zum auslesen von dna code
installiert war
einen weg wenn zierer damit wurden auf
den basen atg und c 1 und 0 um den
computer zu kapern verarbeiteten sie die
so ausgelesene dna-sequenz weiter etwas
ergebnis die sicherheitslücke die wie
am anfang des experiments in die dna
eingeschleust hatten produzierte
tatsächlich einen buffer overflow einen
sogenannten speicher überlauf hierbei
passen keine weiteren daten in den
pufferspeicher des computers diese
interpretiert diesen signal als befehl
eine verbindung zum steuersystem der
angreifer aufzubauen so wurde also
derjenige server kontaktiert der unter
der kontrolle der us forscher und
forscherinnen stadt knapp 40 prozent der
sequenzierte dna abschnitte enthielten
nicht das gewünschte schadprogramm bei
diesem unglaublichen experiment gab es
einige technische hürden zu überwinden
sequenz ihrer zerhacken dna stränge in
kurze abschnitte so dass der code der
schadsoftware in und kurz sein musste
eine weitere einschränkung die vier
wagen atc und g mussten relativ
regelmäßig vorkommen denn ansonsten
würde sich der strang in der backe der
dna strang zusammenfalten wert zu
instabil wurde dass unglaublich an
dieser geschichte ist einfach dass die
daten für den dna heck biologisch wenn
es gibt also keine altbewährten dateien
die den computer befallen sondern
tatsächlich bakterien gleichzeitig
bedeutet das aber auch die offenlegung
einer riesigen sicherheitslücke in
diesem sensiblen bereich denn natürlich
könnten so auch systeme die solche
nicht digitalen daten auslesen gehackt
werden iris oder fingerabdruck scanner
zum beispiel das heißt in einer
kontaktlinse oder einem künstlichen
fingerabdruck könnte schadsoftware
verborgen bleibt in der bioinformatik
denkt jetzt aber trotzdem niemand solch
ein bio hecking szenario eine große
gefahr darstellt zumindest heutzutage
noch nicht dennoch ist der aufwand für
solch ein bio hecking zu groß zunächst
muss dafür erst einmal eine
entsprechende dna sequenz erzeugt und in
das gewünschte sequenziell system
eingeschleust werden zudem hat die
forschungsgruppe bei dem aktuellen
experiment gezielt eine schwachstelle in
die software des sequenztyps eingefügt
um einen erfolg des angriffs überhaupt
zu gewährleisten professionelle hacker
könnten so eine lücke
natürlich finden was aber erheblich
aufwendiger wäre und es ist auch
tatsächlich so dass in kommerziellen
sequenzierung programmen ähnliche
verwundbare stellen vorhanden sein
müssen sind einfach zu komplex fehler
sind normalen programm befasst das
experiment ist also eindeutig gebraucht
werden bringen grundlegende konzepte
für mehr datensicherheit im bereich der
bioinformatik systeme müssen also nicht
nur gegen hacker angriffe aus dem
internet oder gegen infizierte
usb-sticks gesichert werden sondern eben
auch gegen biologische hacks denn im
worst case könnten hacker zukünftig
mit ein wenig fachwissen und
präparierter spucke als ausgangs
element computer kapern
künstliche dna wird derzeit außerdem
von vielen 1 das speichermedium der
zukunft gehandelt das experiment zeigt
dass ich dann auch speicherdienste
gedanken um ihre sicherheit machen wir
bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden wenn er kein video zu
diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann folgt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit bakterien als
datenspeicher
da geht es um ein film der in einer
bakterie gespeichert wurde absoluter
wahnsinn also nicht verpassen und auf
klicken viel spaß dabei und ansonsten
gestank dran